cleaning everything up in the office you
rat rabbit water to course we talk about
ownership and leverage API detectors
that out there beverage
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
now step it up good morning from lagging
other lives sort of trying to I run up
my game a little bit on the lives
oh and this gets paid now just the story
so big shout out everybody if you're
watching my stories he rocks three year
anniversary at vaynermedia
happy birthday Dirac how just raise a
delegate know about the USC football
right straight up for ninety percent of
you this is the greatest year of your
life right now a little bit of the kala
College are we in a ramp are you
fabricated if your shits good right now
quadruple down to me I don't even think
about it as cold-calling I think of it
as more of like business development
right you know it's like you're
introducing yourself and so the word
cold-calling speaks to like just high
volume don't give a [ __ ] to me it's
strategic introduction cold-calling
strategic introductions see I can convey
in this whole thing like see like yeah
the two zero one seven flip challenge
there's all money just sitting people
help people want money people are
spending their lives trying to figure
out how to raise $25,000 for your
startup and they're sitting with $25,000
and [ __ ] clothes garbage or in hustle
like just driving around in midnight and
picking up people's free [ __ ] that they
put on the curb I know it sounds dirty
I like dirty
I'm into dirty dirty how you win
dirty dirty is all you got when you got
nothing
look if you don't want dirty be lucky
and be born into a trust fund you know
win the lotto but when you're [ __ ]
dirty when you're coming from zero
you got a scrap because complaining on
your social media or at the bar ain't
gonna get you [ __ ] goose egg [ __ ]
Nero cool laughter I do here before I've
got this call in five minutes dunk most
morning didn't even ever because it's
true what I don't know which one that
was
you know what's crazy if I make $70,000
a year on each set I mean real happy I
don't we don't when when you need
anything when you expect anything from
others when you don't need anything when
you love losing when you don't give a
[ __ ] about what other people think
you become fundamentally unbeatable and
that's what I had done [ __ ] beatable
because of humility empathy
turning okay it's cool like it started
being interesting how I'm like starting
to figure it out I'm like oh okay
you can't be me what do you do we're
going to do what do you say I like it
like I want more chips on my shoulder I
like why do you think I'm on the jet so
much like it's true though to videos put
out by one shows the brand in the first
three seconds the other one is just much
better and people give a [ __ ] that one
will sell that's real life I understand
I understand I understand that's fine it
what we're pointing to is common sense
and real life and and a world that
trades on things that aren't the metrics
that guide the spend and I'm not naive
to think that that's not a vulnerability
but we have to have a point of view on
this that is going to make us in a 30
year macro correct again I think you
guys have heard this from me we will put
the brand in the first three seconds in
every video as long as and know that we
think their [ __ ] faces for making us do
it the end
hi
hello for you good to see you
morning guys morning hi good good how
are you good good morning
yo me cheese hop on the track like what
up though I know who I am but they
thinking they to shop running a scam
like choco but I have a plan I hope you
plan to keep up though I don't think you
understand that you get it in that like
they try to sell you the mold of the
something I need to tell you and I think
that I think it really helped you these
suckers try to tell the dance you can't
shake it oh my god I know where we can
take it and I know every day you bake in
your giant oh my god I believe with that
in the child let me take you to the
promised land let go let go let me say
goodbye to Instagram and thank you guys
yo yo email this address and say bizdev
if you are a sneaker shop owner an owner
of Instagram accounts or profiles that
play in that in that arena super
grateful driven by gratitude actually I
needed written by gratitude t-shirt
right okay Tyler can you [ __ ] design
that [ __ ] in the next hour
driven by [ __ ] gratitude see ya
anywhere you reading or were you
watching don't know what was what was
the vibes yep good life cycles fine I
think the best thing that's happened to
me in running Vayner was me coming to
the company and saying project
management should be out and then
bringing it back like I I think my
genius is me accepting that I'm a super
naked Emperor yeah like like that's how
you win I don't think I'm a genius I
think I just always evolving yeah and
I'm never bought into my own [ __ ] the
signature creative will be long-form
video for the mobile device on probably
Facebook yeah that's the proper
statement like in 48 months
if it's snapchat if it's red shoe if
it's MySpace's come back I don't know
yeah I don't really care it's the
Internet it's not going to be but it's
not going to be a 30-second spot it's
impossible yeah and that's a big sea
change yeah that's a trillion-dollar sea
change yeah because when you compound
all the digital marketing then ladders
up to the 30-second spot it's not a it's
not just the money poured into a
commercial it's the impact on everything
yeah it's the glue that holds down every
brands communication it is the piece
when that breaks all hell breaks loose
the promised land that show that lemon
let's go
[Music]
there were always people doubted
dishonest
hello another chair for me
hello are you you might have even
thought before you even came like I
believe in it the most like there's
nothing you're going to learn here that
trumps becoming friends with Matt Elena
or Matt simmer it just it's just
inconceivable the end like you should
really literally fundamentally you
should you may be introverted or quiet
like I don't know you right but whatever
you can do and I think the right thing
to do is try to bring value to you know
I've been talking about you know like
like hey I know I'm on the inside
strategy team but hey creative you know
Sally like is anything I can do for you
and it's more not like you should be
working 28 hours it's like if you're
going to sit like here's the thing if
you're going to stay to show that you're
a hustle it's a you want to work here
happiness and you're like okay good way
to do I know Gary spiel and like I'm
going to stay here to nine like that's
going to be like they're going to see
which would be a strategy it'd be really
smart if you did something of meaning to
towards a relationship in that four
hours like work for the sake of work you
know what I mean does speak to hard work
and effort listen I think a lot of the
things I've done in my career were not
smart but I just willed them through
sheer like volume and effort but what is
so much cooler is breaking [ __ ] through
relationships like if you work on your
required account thing from nine to six
it would probably be less scrutinized if
you were helping somebody in production
from eight to ten it may be scrutinized
I mean most of the company's still Falls
like when you're an employee of a
company you're like well this is our
route like I would get that but it's
that's interesting or just like hanging
out with each other Lib relationships
are they only are a lie
it's just they are the skill sets are
going to change too much right like the
skill sets are going to change like the
principles are tried-and-true
like your talent is your talent your
work ethic is your work ethic
but it's the relationships may always be
more doubted disorders when the better
things will be they either know hey
enjoy yeah I guess it is what it is
but you just gotta stay focused thanks
for joining us too so much oh yeah
that's fine cool
hey guys talk to us soon to us you keep
my bag well this is just what like
person wires keep trying to tell you
guys
hey guys are displayed at the Rock idea
way better putting out a lot more
content on article form yes that's ted
dibiase the million dollar man we're
going to span each week read the article
for my podcast details to come who like
three hey guys first of all thank you so
so much for being part of gary view 365
as you guys know I'm obsessed with voice
good morning good afternoon
happy midday I'm obsessed with voice and
I'm just humbled that you're part of
these early days reminds me of my first
five thousand followers on Twitter so
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
laughs let's go let's go let's go
let me think of some plan that's gonna
let me take a little power plan let go
let go let go let me take the Promised
Land
[Music]